-I feel the love!
Welcome, everybody!
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "the Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being here.
Well, guys,
yesterday was Election Day,
and despite some recent polls
that show former President Trump
leading President Biden,
Democrats had
a surprisingly strong night.
Republicans were like,
"How is that possible?"
Democrats were like,
"No, seriously,
how is that possible?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Democrats
had a strong night
in Republican-leaning states
like Kentucky, Ohio,
and Virginia.
It's odd. It's like hearing
BTS swept every category
at tonight's
Country Music Awards.
Yep, yesterday,
Americans went to the polls,
and today we're learning a lot
about the new ballot measures
each state approved.
They're pretty interesting.
For instance, Ohio voted
to legalize marijuana.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Meanwhile, Indiana voted to
enjoy the contact high
from Ohio.
[ Laughter ]
Up next,
New Jersey voted to reclassify
sweatsuits and pinky rings
as "business casual."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey!
-Also, Massachusetts voted to
provide universal Dunkin'
to kids in Pre-K.
Important.
Up next, Montana voted to
reluctantly host your dad on
his "Yellowstone" fanboy trip.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, you're a cowboy."
Up next, Kentucky voted to
change their state motto
to "I'm Just Ken...tucky."
Kind of good.
-Wow.
-West Virginia voted to
charge every tourist $100
if they sing
"Take Me Home, Country Roads."
[ Laughter ]
Here's another one.
Delaware voted to make Joe Biden
2023's Sexiest Man Alive.
Wow. You can make that happen.
And finally, Colorado voted
to legalize marijuana again
because they forgot
they already did.
A lot happened.
Very big day. Important.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some more election news --
the white House said
that polls showing
Biden trailing Trump
in a hypothetical 2024 matchup
should be taken
with a grain of salt.
Although, at Biden's age, maybe
a grain of salt substitute.
Mrs. Dash, Mr. Biden.
Some more political news --
earlier tonight,
NBC aired the third Republican
presidential debate.
It was quite a night.
There were five candidates
on stage,
three moderators
asking questions,
and two people watching at home.
[ Laughter ]
Whatever you think about Trump,
Republican debates are kind of
meaningless without him.
It's like a football game
without Taylor Swift.
[ Laughter ]
But the five candidates
who were there
did everything they could
to get people's attention.
We actually have a photo
from the debate.
I thought that was weird.
It's just...
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this --
a new poll shows that
in his home state of Florida,
Ron DeSantis is trailing Trump.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
I don't think
DeSantis has the right people
running his campaign.
I mean, take a look at this ad
I saw today.
-Some people want me,
Ron DeSantis,
to drop out of the race.
But we don't need less Ron.
We need...More Ron.
We need More Ron
to help the country.
to bring people together,
because even my haters
see me on the street
and yell, "Hey, More Ron!"
-You see what I'm saying?
It's just confusing to me.
That's confusing.
-Wow! That's not a good ad.
-I don't know. I don't think so.
-That is not a good effort.
-Yeah. I don't know. I think
he needs better people.
Some more big news out today.
Ivanka Trump testified
in her dad's New York
civil fraud trial.
Yeah, which is exciting
because now I can complete
my set of Trump
courtroom-sketch trading cards.
[ Laughter ]
Well, switching gears, guys,
tomorrow night is
the "Women Tell All" episode
of "The Golden Bachelor."
-Ooh.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, before Gary decides
between his final three,
we're gonna hear from all
the women he dated this season.
And it looks pretty juicy.
Watch this.
It's "The Golden Bachelor:
Women Tell All."
Gary sent them home,
but now they're back.
We'll hear from Ellen, Susan,
Nancy, Kathy, Blanche,
Rose, Dorothy, Sophia,
Grace and Frankie...
and next year's
Golden Bachelorette...
Madea.
-Hellur!
-Yeah. Interesting.
I can't wait.
That's gonna be good.
"Hellur."
[ Applause ]
Well, some business news.
I saw that Pizza Hut
in Hong Kong
is selling a pizza
topped with snake meat.
[ Audience groans ]
Everyone in Hong Kong
was like, "Ew. Pizza Hut?"
[ Laughter ]
Snake on pizza.
And somehow it's still less
controversial than pineapple.
[ Laughter ]
You like pineapple?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No.
-Absolutely not.
No, no. Absolutely not.
You can't do it.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Finally, I heard
that a menu from the "Titanic"
is expected to sell in auction
for up to $86,000.
$86,000.
That's how desperate people are
for a menu that's not a QR code.
We have a great show tonight.